foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing curses more specifically
we're going to be taking a look at 10 of
the worst cruelest most intense dark
curses in The Wizarding World and
putting them in order I'm going to be
going into what they are and why I
placed them where I did first things
first what is a curse and how does it
differ from say a spell charm Jinx or
hex as far as these categories of magic
go curses most closely resemble charms a
charm is an expression that refers two
spells which adds certain properties to
objects or individuals jobs should not
be confused with transfigurations as
Transfiguration refers to a spell that
changes what the object is rather than
just changing properties of the object
there are countless charms in Harry
Potter that cover all manner of outcomes
there are also different types of charms
another form of charm is an enchantment
though the lines were a bit blurred here
the main difference is that an
enchantment is generally used to apply a
charm-like effect to something for an
extended period of time these would
include protective enchantments like the
videlius charm or protego Maxima and
with the definition of charm solidified
the easiest way to describe a curse is
that it's a dark charm technically a
curse is defined as any spell that
affects an object in a negative manner
typically causing some sort of pain or
discomfort and just like charms there
are also more acute short-lived versions
of curses that contrast the more
stretched out Affliction type curses
within the Potter World the boundaries
are flexible and I imagine Wizards may
have their own ideas this shows that the
categorization of dark charms is not set
in stone and may sometimes be used
interchangeably this explains why some
spells are known by multiple names like
why the slug vomiting charm is a curse
and while the jelly legs curse is also
sometimes known as the jelly legs jinx
this also explains why some curses such
as the leg Locker curse jelly legs curse
and full body bind curse which don't
cause an elasting injury seem to fall
more under the definition of a jinx or
hex while Voldemort's Jinx on the post
of defense against the dark arts teacher
has had serious lasting consequences for
several of those affected which would
seem more like a curse this list will
include both types of curses before we
get started pause the video and comment
your list of what you believe to be the
most horrible curses in Harry Potter I
did a lot of rearranging while working
on this video and I think I'm happy with
how it turned out let's get into it 10.
gormleth gaunts curse what starting
things off this curse produced by Irish
pure-blooded dark witch gormlath gaunt
and of his old Sayer had the ability to
place someone into an enchanted Slumber
you might be thinking that's not so bad
I can get to bed a little easier but the
strength of this curse is what makes it
dangerous this curse is sort of
reminiscent of the one that Afflicted
Snow White
why here this spell certainly deserves
to be on the list but not any higher
than the bottom placing I say this
because the curse itself is relatively
painless and doesn't pose any
significant risk to your mortality the
curse also can be broken if the stimulus
around the victim is significant enough
9. imperious curse the imperious curse
AKA imperio is one of the three
unforgivable curses imperio is most
often used by dark witches and wizards
and when it is cast on a victim they are
forced to perform the unquestioned
bidding of the Caster being under the
control of this spell is said to be like
experiencing a wonderful release from
any sense of responsibility making the
victim extremely susceptible to any sort
of influence from the Caster because of
this adopted Carefree attitude the
victim is inclined to carry out tasks
for the Caster without any sort of moral
comfort office or awareness of the
Caster's intentions or desires why here
I placed the imperial's curse fairly low
on the list because at the end of the
day being placed under the imperious
curse is not a death sentence
furthermore it's been emphasized in the
books that being under the imperial's
curse can actually provide the victim
with some temporary relief from the
stresses of life it was the most
wonderful feeling Harry felt a floating
sensation as every thought in worry in
his head was wiped gently away leaving
nothing but a vague untraceable
happiness the more I think about it the
imperious curse could actually be a
positive and useful tool in the right
hands with just the swish of your wand
you'd be able to give your friends
family members some temporary relief in
the darker times during their lives to
some simply numbing the pain may not be
an advisable strategy but that certainly
depends on the person eight lycanthropy
lycanthropy is a magical condition that
transforms witches Wizards into
werewolves one who suffers from this
condition is called a lycanthrope there
are two ways to become a lycanthrope but
regardless of how it is contracted it is
still considered to be a curse that will
completely alter the victim's existence
the first way to contract lycanthropy is
through being bitten by a werewolf
though in some circumstances the bite
can will kill you the second way is via
the lycacomia curse which apparently
requires nowhere Wolves at all why here
though inheriting lycanthropy doesn't
kill you and to some the prospect of
becoming a werewolf may be exciting I
can assure you that it is no easy
existence the stigma in The Wizarding
World surrounding werewolves is immense
and from the moment you can track this
curse it's unlikely that you will ever
be treated the same furthermore
lycanthropes will often need to live a
very solitary lonely existence as
allowing people to become close to you
only puts their lives in danger this
awful condition also has no cure 7. opal
necklace curse when Harry mistakenly
enters borgenberg's 1992 he sees a
necklace on display with a warning label
do not touch cursed has claimed the
lives of 19 muggle owners to date this
necklace was of course the opal necklace
the same cursed object that Katie Bell
fell victim to in the Half-Blood Prince
It's untelling what cursed the opal
necklace actually possesses but we do
know that it can cause some serious
damage to those who happen to come into
physical contact with it Katie Millie
touched it through a small hole in her
glove and it took her six months to
recover in Saint mungo's why here this
curse is nothing to scoff at but at the
end of the day there are much worse
curses out there yeah it's highly lethal
but touching it is not necessarily A
death sentence and it's also pretty easy
to avoid 6. curse on marvelo gone to
ring the curse on Marvel gaunts ring was
an invention of Lord Voldemort who
created it in an effort to protect his
horcruxes Dumbledore famously contracts
this curse when he places the cursed
ring on his finger in that moment
securing his Fate The Curse is thought
to be extremely deadly ticking down even
Dumbledore and the only reason that he
was able to survive as long as he did
was with the help of Severus Snape the
symptoms of the curse mimic necrosis
slowly turning the affected areas black
and effectively killing that part of
your body why here I think this
placement on the list is suitable as the
curses effectively a slightly worse
version of The Curse contracted via the
opal necklace the main difference here
being that this curse will eventually
kill you and only seems to get worse
over time
5. blood malediction maledictus a
maledictus curse is applied to and
inherited through a witch or Wizard's
bloodline a dark curse that is passed on
through generations of family members
and is transferred from mother to
daughter a maledictus suffers from a
blood malediction a type of curse that
causes the sufferer to slowly transform
into an animal over the course of their
life the animal can vary according to
the specific curse in Harry Potter the
main maledictus that comes to mind is
nagini whose blood malediction meant
that she was destined to turn into a
snake becoming less human and more Snake
each and every day in early life the
maledictus will possess the ability to
transform it well but that's what slips
over time eventually you will lose the
ability to transform and will be stuck
in whatever animal form that is destined
for you why here though blood
malediction doesn't kill you it's an
Affliction that leads to a very isolated
lonely existence it's an awful curse
that you're born with and have no way
out of it's an inescapable curse that
eats away at you slowly stripping away
your identity I imagine that suffering
from this curse would induce a form of
claustrophobia as with each passing day
the curse goes stronger further trapping
you into a permanent animal state if
that isn't bad enough once fully
transformed you completely lose the
ability to explain yourself or
communicate with your own kind
4. killing curse the killing curse
otherwise known as Avada Kedavra is a
curse that kills the victim in the blink
of an eye causing instantaneous death if
you want to kill someone with no fuss
then this is certainly the spell to use
after uttering the incantation the spell
produces a blindingly intense green bolt
of light right before the victim simply
drops dead there are two theories for
how they die the first claiming that the
victim's internal organs cease to
function after being struck and the
second claiming that the soul of the
victim is magically ripped from their
body
why here the only reason that the
killing curse isn't higher on the list
is that we're lacking information if the
curse does indeed rip the soul out of
the body then perhaps the killing curse
is one of the worst ways to die however
if it simply causes your organs to shut
down then this is potentially one of the
more remorseful ways to kill people as
they are gone instantly with no
suffering to speak of 3. entrail
expelling curse the entrail expelling
curse is fairly self-explanatory it's a
curse that forces your entrails insides
organs to be magically expelled ripped
from the body this curse is
unquestionably lethal why here this
curse kills you fairly brutally which is
why it's high up on a list however there
are no real drawn out torturous effects
2. cruciatus curse the cruciatus curse
otherwise known as crucio is one of the
Unforgivable curses in essence grusio is
the spell used for torture which makes
perfect sense if we consider that crucio
translates to my torture in Latin when
cast crucio inflicts excruciating pain
on the victim pain so excruciating that
it is considered to be torturous casting
crucio is said to require a wand and
incantation and its effects are said to
vary depending on the Caster's desires
and emotions to produce the excruciating
pain implied by the name the Caster must
despise the victim and enjoy causing
pain Harry Potter after crucia was cast
on him described it as feeling like his
head was being split open while having
his bones set on fire why here there are
a few reasons for why crucio is so high
up on the list the first reason being
that the pain induced to Via crucio is
said to be so excruciating that in some
cases death would be preferable the next
reason is that crucio when applied to a
victim for long enough is said to cause
permanent effects like brain damage this
happened to Neville Longbottom's parents
after being tortured relentlessly the
long bottoms lost everything that made
them who they were living out the rest
of their lives as broken Shadows of
their former selves this Bell is
particularly awful if we consider the
fact that the loved ones of these
victims will forever have to witness
them in this state all while knowing
that they were tortured in their final
moments 1. transmography and torture oh
boy where do I start with this one this
sadistic curse that a lot of you may not
know about effectively combines the
effects of crucio with a form of
transmogrification or Transfiguration
this terrible curse does indeed kill its
victims but not before causing them
intense torturous pain stretched out of
a considerable period of time why here
if we look at the etymology of the
cursor's name which features
transmogrify it would suggest that the
curse stretches the victim in a
multitude of directions
grotesquely contorting their bodies
until they die the combination of the
fact that this spell is lethal and
tortures you in unprecedented ways makes
this an easy choice for the List's top
spawns why this isn't an unforgivable
curse when it features aspects from two
of the existing unforgivable curses is
beyond me and that's it for this video
which curses had you heard of was your
list similar to mine leave a comment
down below until next time remember it
does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
[Music]